there are so many of you that graduate
this month and have no [ __ ] idea what
you want to do and that's okay
most people don't you don't realize that
you're entering the greatest five-year
window of your life this is the best and
easiest five years of your life because
this is when you need to attack what you
love and what you want to do here's why
you don't have all the baggage you may
have college loans respect it's hard as
[ __ ] you may have the expectations of
your parents mentally hard you may have
a lot of other things but this is
exactly when you can live with four
roommates in a basement and eat [ __ ]
fast food that you don't have to worry
about getting that job what you should
do is go and travel and learn go and
start that business that you've always
wanted promise me all you youngsters
that are watching this right now in the
[ __ ] comments because i'll jump in
and talk to you promise me that you
understand that the land grab of
happiness
starts right now